so it's all about safety with the crop
so okay here i am this is my view so
when we pull the crock out of the trap
we put top jaw ropes over here and then
we pull them out and the crocodile will
actually death roll they'll roll over
they'll thrash around and
then exactly that's it
once they've got their mouth and you you
now i can't go from there once their
mouth is bound up with that rope that's
when the jump team gets in position so
oh no he's got me oh that can't be we
don't want to happen so then jump team's
ready no no i'm not not done yet okay
now when you jump on the crocodile you
wait for the perfect time and then all
of a sudden you just go bam jump on the
croc it's usually thrashing around so
thrash around a bit trash around
like this and then you've got to hold
them okay
and then once they're secure then you
can do all the science with them and
then release them back into the wild